STEVE: IT’S 7:02 HERE IN THE
EAST.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LARA TRUMP, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
LARA, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
BY THE WAY ANOTHER SET ON
CHARLOTTE IT IS FOUR HOURS AWAY
FROM MY HOMETOWN OF WILMINGTON,
NORTH CAROLINA.
BRIAN: THERE YOU GO.
AINSLEY: THAT’S WHERE YOU WENT
TO GO SHOPPING, RIGHT, WHEN YOU
WERE A YOUNG GIRL YOU STILL ARE
YOUNG.
>> WE WENT TO RALEIGH AND WE
WENT TO CHARLOTTE.
AINSLEY: WE DID, TOO.
STEVE: IT’S GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
YESTERDAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE OUR
CORRESPONDENT ASKED JEN PSAKI
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW DID A NUMBER OF
TIMES.
AND THIS IS GO TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
BUT, IT WASN’T ABOUT WHEN WAS
THE LAST TIME.
IT WAS A LITTLE MORE EXPABSSIVE
AND THE ANSWER IS SHOCKING.
WATCH THIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN EVER BEEN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> IN HIS LIFE?
>> YES.
>> I WILL HAVE TO GET -- LOOK
BACK IN MY HISTORY BOOKS AND
CHECK THE TIME HE HAS BEEN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING ALL
MORNING AND WE CANNOT FIND ANY
RECORD OF HIM VISITING THE
BORDER AS PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, SENATOR, OR EVEN AS A
CONCERNED CITIZEN.
WHY WOULD THAT BE?
>> I CAN CHECK AND SEE WHEN THE
LAST TIME OR WHEN HE MAY HAVE
BEEN BUT TELL ME MORE ABOUT WHY
YOU ARE ASKING?
>> BECAUSE THIS IS A PRESIDENT
WHO MAKES A POINT WHEN THERE ARE
DISASTERS IN THIS COUNTRY LIKE A
WILDFIRE OR HURRICANES TO GO AND
SEE FOR HIMSELF FIRSTHAND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY SO THAT HE CAN HAVE AN
INFORMED POB TO MAKE POLICY.
WHY DOESN’T HE DO THAT -- WHY
DOESN’T HE GO DOWN TO DEL RIO,
TEXAS AND SEE WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, PETER, I
THINK THE SITUATION AT THE
BORDER IS THE RESULT OF A BROKEN
SYSTEM.
AND THE PRESIDENT CERTAINLY
RELIES ON HIS EXPERIENCE.
STEVE: SO, LAW, YESTERDAY PETER
IN OUR BRAIN ROOM LOOKED FOR
HOURS, COULD NOT FIND ANY RECORD
OF JOE BIDEN EVER BEING AT THE
U.S.-MEXICAN BORDER.
>> CAN I JUST SAY THAT I AM SO
GLAD THAT WE HAVE PETER DOOCY AT
THE WHITE HOUSE ASKING REAL
QUESTIONS AND THESE AREN’T --
THEY SHOULDN’T BE TOUGH
QUESTIONS BY THE WAY.
THESE ARE VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
QUESTIONS THAT SHOULD BE EASY TO
ANSWER.
BUT IT SEEMS TO GIVE THE PRESS
SECRETARY THERE A REAL HARD TIME
WHEN HE IS THERE WE ARE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HIM ASKING
ACTUAL QUESTIONS.
BUT YOU HEARD JEN PSAKI THERE
DARE I SAY DID SHE SLIP UP,
GUYS, AND PERHAPS TELL THE TRUTH
THAT JOE BIDEN IS ACTUALLY
RELYING ON HIS EXPERIENCE HERE.
HIS FIVE DECADES OF DOING JUST
ABOUT NOTHING FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND APPLYING IT TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER?
I THINK THAT’S PRETTY ACCURATE.
HE IS DOING NOTHING DOWN THERE.
YOU WOULD THINK, TO PETER’S
POINT, IF YOU HAVE A COMPLETE
CRISIS AT HAND, WHETHER IT’S
WILDFIRES, WHETHER IT’S
HURRICANES, WHETHER IT’S MASS
SHOOTINGS, WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ALWAYS GOES TO THOSE
AREAS AND AS HE REFERENCED,
TALKS TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND
SAYS WHAT DO YOU NEED?
HOW CAN WE HELP?
>> JOE BIDEN IS COMPLETELY
ABSENT IN THIS SCENARIO.
BUT, MAYBE THERE IS A MORE
SINISTER REASON.
MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE THIS IS ALL
PURPOSEFUL.
MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE THEY WANT
THESE MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS POURING INTO OUR
COUNTRY PERHAPS THESE ARE THE
FUTURE VOTERS FOR THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS
INCREDIBLY DISENFRANCHISED WITH
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE FIRST 8
MONTHS OF THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, IS
THERE A BIGGER REASON?
HE HASN’T EVEN BOTHERED TO GO
DOWN THERE.
MAYBE THEY WANT IT TO HAPPEN.
AINSLEY: CLOSEST WE COULD FIND
IN GUATEMALA IN 2014 TO
INVESTIGATE ROOT CAUSES.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
BRIAN: IN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
THEY SAID WHEN HE WAS DRAWING UP
HIS IMMIGRATION POLICIES
OFFICIALS IN HIS CABINET WERE
SAYING MAYBE YOU SHOULD HOLD
ONTO THE TRUMP POLICY KNOWN AS
REMAIN IN MEXICO.
AT WHICH TIME THEY DECIDED HE
DECIDED NOT TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE TRUMP HAD BECOME SO
TOXIC.
SO, RATHER THAN SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
HE WANTED TO PLAY POLITICS.
IT SOUNDS EXACTLY LIKE
AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT SOUNDS EXACTLY LIKE
AND, YEAH, WE HAVE A SOLUTION.
IT IS TO DO WHAT DONALD TRUMP
DID.
BECAUSE THAT WAS WORKING.
FINISH THE WALL.
WE SAW THAT THEY HAD TO BUILD
BASIC LAY WALL WITH VEHICLES
DOWN THERE TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
COMING OVER THE BORDER.
WALLS WORK.
WE KNOW THAT FINISH BUILDING THE
WALL.
KEEP THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY.
REIMPLEMENT THE POLICY THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD PUT IN
BECAUSE THEY WERE WORKING BUT
JOE BIDEN COULDN’T HELP HIMSELF.
HE HAD TO DO AWAY WITH EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD PUT IN PLACE.
SO, YOU ARE RIGHT, BRIAN.
IT IS PREPOSTEROUS TO SEE THIS
HAPPEN IN AMERICA THAT THIS GUY
WOULD RATHER PLAY POLITICS THAN
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
SADLY THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE ON
OUR HANDS RIGHT NOW WITH JOE
BIDEN AS PRESIDENT.
AINSLEY: WE KNOW WHEN YOUR
FATHER-IN-LAW WAS PRESIDENT HE
WAS PRO-ISRAEL AND SUPPORTED THE
IRON DOME WHICH HAS SAVED THE
LIVES OF SO MANY ISRAELIS.
WE NORMALLY CONTRIBUTE TO THE
IRON DOME.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO GIVE
$1 BILLION FOR THAT DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
THE FUNDS WAS REMOVED ON TUESDAY
FROM THIS GOVERNMENT FUNDING
PACKAGE AFTER A LOT OF PRESSURE
FROM THE SQUAD.
THERE IS NOW A DEMOCRAT FROM
CONNECTICUT CONGRESSWOMAN ROSA
DID HE LAYER ROW, SHE IS A HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR SHE WANTS
THAT FUNDING PUT BACK IN PLACE.
STEVE: GOOD.
AINSLEY: SHE IS SPRUCING A NEW
BILL.
THE UNITED STATES COMMITMENT TO
THE SECURITY OF OUR FRIEND AND
ALLY ISRAEL IS IRONCLAD.
REPLENISHERRING INTERCEPTORS
USED TO PROTECT ISRAEL FROM THE
ATTACKS IS OUR LEGAL AND MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
WHILE THIS FUNDING WOULD
ORDINARILY BE INCLUDED IN A
YEAR-END SPENDING PACKAGE WE ARE
ADVANCING THIS LEGS NOW TO
BIPARTISAN COMMITMENT TO
ISRAEL’S SECURITY AS PART OF A
MIDDLE EAST WITH LASTING PEACE.
SO WHY DO YOU THINK THE SQUAD IS
AGAINST GIVING ISRAEL THIS MONEY
WHICH PROTECTS THEIR PEOPLE?
>> SADLY THEY HAVE SHOWN THEY
HATE CENTRAL ISRAEL.
THEY HAVE SHOWN ANTI-SEMITISM AT
EVERY SINGLE TURN.
IT’S HORRIBLE TO SEE.
ISRAEL IS OUR MIDDLE EASTERN
ALLY.
THEY ARE THE ONLY FREE NATION IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
GOSH, WE OUGHT TO WANT TO
PROTECT THEM AND OUGHT TO WANT
TO PROTECT THAT COUNTRY.
WE ALWAYS HAVE.
I THINK THE SCARIEST PART OF
THIS IS IF YOU EVER WONDER WHO
WAS ACTUALLY IN CONTROL OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IS THESE WOMEN
COULD TAKE $1 BILLION AND MAKE
IT ZERO DOLLARS?
BASICALLY IN THE MATTER OF
HOURS, THAT’S YOUR ANSWER.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE RUNNING THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IT WAS NOT HYPERBOLE WHEN WE
SUGGESTED THAT THERE WERE SUG
SOCIALISTS RUNNING THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
IT IS THESE WOMEN.
AND HERE IS YOUR PROOF.
THAT IS A REALLY SCARY THING FOR
THE FUTURE OF AMERICA IF
DECISIONS LIKE THIS CAN BE MADE
BY A VERY SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT REPRESENT THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN.
WHOSE VALUES ARE FAR OUTSIDE OF
THE BOUNDS OF ANYTHING, YOU KNOW
THAT WE HAVE EVER CONSIDERED
AMERICAN, WHAT DOES THAT SAY FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY IS
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE NOW IN
CHARGE?
STEVE: LISTEN, MAC MILLER WHO IS
RUNNING FOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF THE GREAT STATE OF NEVADA,
WENT TO THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF
CLARK COUNTY IN NEVADA.
AND HE WANTED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF, YOU KNOW, HIS POINT OF
VIEW, THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
COVID AND ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
THERE HE IS BEING DRAGGED OUT OF
THE MEETING, THEY RAMMED HIM
INTO, I’M SURE, IT WAS
ACCIDENTAL BUT NONETHELESS THEY
THREW HIM THROUGH METAL
DETECTOR.
HERE IS HE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT HE THINKS WHY
IT HAPPENED, HE IS MAC MILLER.
>> THE COUNTY COMMISSION
MEETINGS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE RUN
BY THE COMMISSIONERS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CLARK COUNTY HERE IN
NEVADA.
AND THOSE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO
ASK QUESTIONS.
AND BE INTERESTED IN WHAT’S ON
THE AGENDA AT THESE MEETINGS.
AND WHAT WAS ON THE AGENDA AT
THIS MEETING WAS A PROCLAMATION
TO BASICALLY DO AWAY WITH
NEVADA’S CLARK COUNTY’S FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
AND I WAS THERE TO WITNESS AND
OPPOSE THIS PROCLAMATION.
AND THAT DIDN’T GET TO HAPPEN.
BECAUSE I WAS ATTACKED AFTER
TRYING TO DEFEND THE PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTY.
THEY WILL NEVER STOP ME, MAC
MILLER FROM BEING ABLE TO DEFEND
THEM AND NEVER PREVENT ME FROM
COMING OUT TO DEFEND THE PEOPLE
OF THIS GREAT STATE OF NEVADA.
STEVE: LAURALARA AT THAT PARTICU
MEETING THE 5-2 SPREADING
COVID-19 MISINFORMATION IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
HE WANTED TO SPEAK OUT BUT,
OBVIOUSLY, AND PERHAPS IT WAS
BECAUSE HE WAS A REPUBLICAN, NOT
ALLOWED.
AND THAT’S WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> YEAH.
ANY DISSENTING MACHINE WILL GET
THIS -- THIS IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN
TO YOU.
BASICALLY WHERE WE ARE HEADED IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW UNDER DEMOCRAT
CONTROL IS THAT IF YOUR OPINION
DOES NOT DIRECTLY ALIGN WITH
THEIRS, AND YOU ARE NOT PUTTING
INFORMATION OUT THAT THEY AGREE
WITH, THEN YOU ARE SILENCED.
YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT IS
IMMEDIATELY TAKEN AWAY.
YOU SAW IT HAPPEN HERE.
WHAT A TERRIBLE SCENE.
THIS SHOULDN’T HAPPEN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND I THINK IT’S VERY, TRE VERY
BRIGHTENING THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED SO QUICKLY HERE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO PUBLIC
DISCOURSE?
WHAT HAPPENED TO US SHARING
OPINIONS AND WE CAN ALL GAIN
FROM THAT.
THAT USED TO BE THE WAY OF
THINGS AND I WOULD SHARE MY
OPINION AND YOU COULD SHARE
YOURS.
AND WE CAN LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER.
BUT NOW THAT IS OVER.
THOSE DAYS ARE GONE.
NOW UNLESS YOUR VIEWS, AS I
SAID, ALIGN DIRECTLY WITH WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS AND BIG TECH WANT
TO HAVE OUT THERE.
YOU ARE SILENCED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOU ARE KICKED OUT OF
MEETING LIKE THIS.
AND WE SEE IT HAPPEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
BRIAN: YEAH.
YOU REMEMBER THE PRESIDENT SAID
HIS PATIENCE IS WEARING THIN
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ARE GETTING ON HIS NERVES A
LITTLE BIT WE SEE.
ALSO, WHAT’S GREAT OUR ALLIES
REALLY FEEL WELCOMED.
FRANCE JUST RECOMMEND THEIR
AMBASSADOR AND ISRAEL LEFT NAKED
IN FRONT OF HAMAS THANKS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT’S A GREAT MESSAGE.